now marie in october you released a new
special on byu tv called an evening with
marie and this seems to be
like a real celebration of all the
musical chapters in your life will you
tell me about that
well i chose first of all byutv i chose
it because the app is free and it's on
everything you can download it anywhere
and i wanted to do that um
just because i mean they have over 50
million viewers that goes worldwide and
the military can get it as well it did
i've always done a lot of things for uso
and people like that but
um
but uh it's fun it's an evening with and
one of the things that i wanted to do
especially coming out of this pandemic
and people starting to perform again
drew
is to me
you know how you play different
characters i play different vocal styles
and it's been a lifetime of learning how
to do it from you know country to jazz
to pop to uh legit soprano to belt to
operatic it's really really challenging
it's been my goal to do that so in this
show you're just going to get a little
sampling it's not my full symphonic show
but we have a a full symphonic orchestra
and music um
when you hear it in that context where
everything is live it hits everything
from your chakras to the tones to the to
the uh the lows to the highs and it is
so fun i have video from six decades uh
it's just
you'll hear everything that i mean it's
it's a super fun show download it it's
free and you'll get a little taste of
some of the songs from the album too now
your latest album um is unexpected uh
that is the title that is beautiful by
the way
um that's that i have a child calling me
on my phone hold on
okay turn it off there we go um i i
i so fail you right now i always keep it
there in case they need me and i'll go
are you okay yes okay i'll call you back
uh well that's depressed but anyway i
was in vegas and my son called me
and i i
hit i'll talk to you later and then i
never did
so
sorry
no i um i so it's something that is very
important to me uh to always have my
phone on for my children
i'm so sorry that that happened no
you know what it's uh it's one of those
things that you go through uh i lost my
son um
he was 18.
and i'm really good i'm okay it's just
every now and then you know people say
do you ever get over it no you never do
um but god gives you respects and that's
you hit triggers that just happened to
be a trigger sorry about that no i i
totally understand um i really do our
lives are
full of triggers and
they come up at the most unexpected time
speaking of the title can i ask if it's
possible to ask you a piece of life
advice that
when something
does throw you i know anything and rock
your world like it just did
how beautifully you just handled it and
there's people out there
um
i
i'm i'm i'm just wondering if you have
any life advice for
how one might be able to handle a
trigger oh well
i i think that god never gives you
anything that you can't handle i don't
know that god gives them to you but i
know that people have agency to make
choices that affect you
and i believe that
when life is
too much to stand i get on my knees and
i beg and
i just know somehow he gives you that
comfort with my son
you know a lot of people judge me very
harshly that i went back to work uh you
understand that drew you know you're
kind of
you do everything on a national level
instead of a private level uh within
your community or whatever
but um i had to choose to go back to
work because i had seven more children
that were hurting and they needed
to know that you had to keep living life
and so and i felt that was uh
something that i wanted to do for them
despite what people were saying thank
you i'm very very grateful for your
answer and your candor and i agree with
the fight and i thank you
[Music]